foreign
[Music]
mysterious and consuming everything
around them
black holes will rip apart anything that
passes their Event Horizon but could
there be more
what would happen if you fell into one
of these monstrosities
how could you possibly travel through
the black hole itself
and if you emerged out the other side
where would you end up
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you traveled through a black
hole
black holes aren't that much different
than any other object in the universe
that has mass except that they are
really really dense
at their Center is a singularity
basically an infinitely small point
where all their matter is compressed
the more matter that's packed into a
black hole's Singularity the stronger
its gravitational pull
considering that some black holes are
the remnants of stars with more than 10
times the mass of our sun
they have a lot of gravity
and every black hole has an event
horizon
this is the point of no return
once you crossed that there's no way
back out
and unless you traveled as fast as the
speed of light you wouldn't be able to
escape it
we don't know exactly what happens to
something Beyond The Event Horizon
because once something is past it
there's no way of sending a message back
but odds are gravity would rip you apart
Adam by Adam
unless there was some other way out
if you were lucky enough you wouldn't
just be venturing into the unknown
depths of any normal black hole you'd be
crossing the Event Horizon of a Charged
black hole equipped with a one-way
Wormhole that connects the black hole
with a white hole now white holes are
strange instead of consuming all matter
in their path like black holes do they
only spit stuff back out into space and
nothing is able to enter a white hole
except you wouldn't just cross the Event
Horizon and end up spat out on the other
side
you'd better be ready for one of the
most mind-blowing experiences the
universe has to offer
as you were preparing for the trip of a
Lifetime on the outskirts of the black
hole you'd see stars twisted around a
perfect circle of Darkness
it's too bad there wouldn't be much time
to enjoy the view this gravitational
monster would start pulling you toward
it faster and faster
gravitational force of a black hole is
unbelievably strong
it's so strong that it would turn you
into spaghetti
if you were falling feet first your legs
would experience a significantly more
intense gravitational pull than your
head
your body would get stretched into
Oblivion
well we don't want that to happen to you
just yet so let's say you'd fall into a
wormhole just before the black hole rip
you apart and don't forget you'd be
traveling through not just any black
hole but a Charged one
Not only would there be a wormhole
lurking inside it but this black hole
would also have two event Horizons
but as you were crossing the space
between the two points of no return
you'd likely not realize what's happened
you'd be in free fall and as you'd fall
deeper you'd find the black circle in
front of you appear to grow bigger and
bigger if the black hole was as large as
the one at the center of the Milky Way
this would take about 20 seconds
and with all the painful
spaghettification you'd be experiencing
those 20 seconds would seem to last for
an eternity
but once you approached the inner
Horizon the black hole would appear to
stop expanding and then surprisingly it
would seem to shrink
almost like you started falling away
from it for a moment you might think
you've already cleared it but this
wouldn't be the case it's only an
optical illusion you're still in free
fall
this trick on the eyes is caused by
something known as relativistic beaming
all it would do is squeeze what you see
in front of you to make it appear as if
the black hole was shrinking and the
light from the rest of the universe
outside the black hole would appear
brighter around its edges
but as you finally pass the inner
Horizon that wouldn't be the only light
you'd see at this point you'd be
overwhelmed by an energetic bright burst
and not just any old boring burst of
light
witnessing a reflection of the entire
history of our universe
seen through the singularity of the
black hole
within the inner Event Horizon you'd now
be careening Through the Wormhole
connecting you to the white hole
but if you thought being stretched was
bad enough think again you'd be trapped
in an extremely unstable phenomena
the enormous gravitational forces of the
black hole would threaten to obliterate
the Wormhole any second
as you were crossing the second Event
Horizon you'd see another energetic
burst of light but this time instead of
seeing a reflection of the universe's
entire past
see its future
keep in mind this wouldn't be the future
of the universe as you know it
and you wouldn't just be passing through
the singularity of the black hole and
out the other side no you'd be about to
get spewed out by a white hole into a
completely different Universe from your
own
finally you'd be out of the white hole
as the distance between you and it
increased you'd also see all the light
from our current universe that came
along for the ride with you
and hey congratulations you'd be the
first person to explore an entirely new
universe
there could be so many incredible things
for you to discover
could find yourself in a parallel
universe another version of you could be
living the best life you've always
imagined for yourself
but hey I mean you just traveled through
a black hole so how much better could it
get
unfortunately the news might not all be
good
you could be stuck having to follow
completely different laws of physics
from the ones we know
gravity could be weaker stronger or even
non-existent
and the building blocks of matter could
be made from dark matter
or they could be made up of antimatter
in which case you're mind-blowing
Joyride would be about to meet a deadly
end
antimatter and ordinary matter like What
You're Made Of would annihilate each
other upon contact
and worst of all you wouldn't be able to
just turn around and return home
remember you couldn't jump back into the
white hole because it doesn't suck
anything into it that was a one-way trip
sorry
well I hope it was fun while it lasted
maybe it would be nicer if you could see
into a black hole before falling through
it
what would that look like
well that's a story for another
what if